he's probably one of the most recognized
high school players in history
okay stop in public it's a zoo it's an
absolute zoo there is no privacy there
is no sit down and have a meal there's
gawking pointing staring selfies with
people violating his personal space
without asking him there's more to taco
fall there's so much more there
when I'm in public like I take a lot of
pictures I cannot turn down pictures I
put myself in that place if that was me
and I see a guy that was seven foot six
and I was not that tall
I would be surprised I would want
something I can have that would help me
remember this guy he's embraced it you
know especially at the next level you're
gonna get the same thing so get used to
doing interviews get used to the camera
being in your face get used to people
walking up to you get just two kissing
babies growing up in Senegal I didn't
know much about best honestly I was told
I was a kid I was really excited I was
like wow I'm going to the United States
then once I'll end it that's where I
realized I might not see my brother my
mom my family for a long time I probably
wouldn't be playing basketball at night
I didn't coming in you guys the first
tile we saw we were just in awe of his
size there not a lot of people walking
around at seven six and at the time he
wasn't very strong but you could tell he
had a lot of potential I remember when I
first got here I couldn't go up and down
the court once I was getting tired
I was wake I was not strong mentally
physically nothing 90% of being a good
player is mental Taco didn't really
think he was a dominant player we just
kept home in an taco you can do this you
can do this you can do it
you saw his confidence level rise it was
really good for me mentally memory
realized that these guys were not
actually better than meand I can compete
with them and not only that I can
dominate
I remember when he and I were driving
alone and he said to me I'm finally
starting to feel like a basketball
player his presence sure really makes a
difference you see how it's a great fit
for him he's gonna take their program to
another level as well I've had some
really good big guys I'd coached the
Florida Joakim Noah out for four we were
looking for a guy we felt that could be
the centerpiece of our program and I
thought tacos outside was through the
roof he's got two high-level NBA
qualities already one he can rebound to
he can block shots he's a rim protector
so he has the ability to be like I'm a
Tumbo to impact the game and he'll have
a chance to grow into that if he chooses
to
[Music]
people see taco and assume basketball
player because he's tall but basketball
doesn't seem to be his number one goal
in life I have a lot of aspirations like
sometimes I think I have too much
aspiration first I wanted to do like
chemistry and then I was like no I would
get into engineering and I was like
maybe I can do both his effort into
school is relentless he works harder at
school and he does a basketball it's
really astounding because he can do
things that I cannot even do being able
to multiply those large numbers in his
head as quickly as he does it's a real
treat sometimes to watch the other
students faces when he just spouts the
answer out so quickly and they're still
punching it into their calculator
there's a difference between just
getting accepted to school to go play
basketball and actually get accepted
into the engineering program
I wasn't handed to him I mean he had to
have the math the science the test
scores the GPA to pull that off if I
could be LeBron James and Steve Jobs I
would mr. Jones
because your athleticism would fail one
day but your knowledge will last forever
and you will be able to impact people
for a longer period of time basketball
can be really helpful to me to
accomplish big things it's gonna be
really helpful for me to have that kind
of finances I can go back to my country
of people open businesses open lab I
think taco understands the mindset of
basketball being just a small portion of
really who he is and that's what makes
taco beautiful a person is his humility
his spirits and his mindset of
understanding you know that there's much
more out there than just basketball this
really incredible unique creature really
is gonna do something big beyond just
basketball my mom I've known so much for
me man I have to be able to be a method
to my little brother and my dad also has
been really working hard that's how I
told myself I'm just gonna knock success
[Music]